robin hood for example in the uh in the
traditional markets
starts out brokerage first and then
tries to from a growth perspective go
geographic expansion
you know step one step two is add other
products to kind of their product suite
it's pretty hard for a brokerage
business to add other types of products
if they're not
other brokerage products right so you
can add derivatives and futures and
things like that but
if you want to get into credit cards
debit cards you know deposit type
accounts cash accounts all that kind of
stuff is
pretty difficult if you compare that to
like a square
square starts out with deposits and
payments they then end up adding crypto
they add cards they add
you know pdp um payment product they've
added
fractional shares or kind of their own
brokerage business like deposits and
payments seem to be
kind of a stronger place to start if
your goal is to have a very robust
product suite and i think that in crypto
you guys have
been kind of the leader or one of the
companies that realized this early and
you start out with deposits payments
and now i've continued to add these
services maybe talk a little bit about
how you guys think about
kind of the deposit being so important
to the business model and then how you
think about
adding you know other products to the
suite over time
sure well your you know your ability to
monetize uh and create revenue on a
financial services platform is generally
a derivative of balances on the platform
so if you you know if you if you have
more customers who are holding more
assets on your platform
um then you have a better chance of
being able to you know make money
uh off of those assets so it's kind of
uh it's always a game about you know
getting balances and then figuring out
ways to
uh you know monetize those balances
which intersects with
enabling your customers to do more
things with them or you know launching
more products
so um you know that's the way we've
always we've always thought about it one
of the other reasons why this is
important
is uh financial services is a is a you
know kind of hyper competitive
industry and i think crypto is even more
competitive than traditional financial
services because you're competing on a
global scale
you know with blockchain technology
and everyone at least everyone that's in
the industry already sees the
opportunity so there's a lot
of you know investment and excitement
and smart people working in the space
and so you know we believed uh from
really early on that a core part of our
strategy has to be
uh constantly releasing new products
that add value for our clients
so that you know one you can add
monetization into the platform from
these balances that you know should be
growing
but two you can create stickiness with
folks so we've kind of
thought about the end goal for us in
terms of the client relationship that we
want to have as being
the equivalent to you know when someone
gets a
mailer and this probably happens to you
i know it happens to me all the time
from a bank and they're like hey we'll
give you 200 to open up a new checking
account
and you throw it away not because 200
dollars
you know wouldn't be nice to have but
because you do all your stuff with uh
with a certain bank you kind of got your
setup
figured out in terms of you know where
your checking and savings account are
where your credit cards are where your
mortgage is and you don't want to go
through the you know
work and pain in the butt of switching
all that stuff just for 200
so that's the type of relationship we
want to have with our clients and the
way you do that
is create a compelling product suite so
that someone can you know not only earn
interest on their bitcoin
but they can also get a loan against
their portfolio if they ever need to
they can buy and sell it if they ever
need to
um we're really excited about uh our
first product that we're launching
in the payment space which is going to
be a bitcoin rewards credit card so you
can
spend money every day on a credit card
and earn bitcoin as rewards for it and
that's just going to flow into your
interest account uh immediately when you
get the rewards
um and uh if someone
engages with all those products and then
they get a you know letter in the mail
from
another company saying hey we'll give
you 100 worth of bitcoin
to come try and do some of those same
things that you're doing with block fi
over here we want them to just throw it
away it's not worth it i'm happy with
block five they give they've given me
you know great client service i trust
the team
and the product i'm familiar with how it
works it's really easy to use
um and so you know that's that's the end
goal for us
yeah and one of the things that that has
been really interesting uh
for me to see is this default
digital currency world that you've
created so when somebody
brings money into the system it doesn't
sit in cash ever
right it sits in a stable coin and so
kind of explain
how that works and why that's important
because i do think that it also changes
the mindset of a user right like you are
in this digital ecosystem
um let's talk a little bit about that
yeah so i mean
first off just in case anybody doesn't
understand a stable coin um
you know imagine if uh well you know jim
and i
coinbase couple other folks have done
this let's use gemiini
for this example um folks send them
money they hold it in a bank account
and they they you know get that audited
and the cash just sits in a bank
somewhere
but then they release one-to-one um
digital
versions of those dollars in a bank
account for them it's called
gusd the gemini dollar and so uh when
you fund a block fight account from your
bank which you can do via a wire
transfer
it doesn't sit as dollars at block by it
sits as gusd
but that's basically interchangeable
with dollars you can you know
wire it back out to your bank account
but the reason we represent it that way
is that
it enables us to
kind of do some of the things that we
want to do without falling squarely into
traditional types of regulatory boxes
and uh you get all the benefits of
having it as cryptocurrency which are
you know you can
transfer it on blockchain payment rails
uh
you're you know taking part in this in
this new ecosystem
and it is a little bit different than
just holding a dollar in a bank account
but
in ways that are largely positive